Speaker 1: Let's go next to a guy from Killeen,
Texas, Sky. Welcome. I can hear you. Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: So I had a question that just a
little bit more in like the conspiratorial route
regarding like Trump's views on like political
views. He's never really ever made sense to me
as like a because I'm a Democrat. And whenever
you hear Democrats speak about Republicans,
sometimes you hear like and take the most
extreme views on abortion or something where,
you know, they say the mother needs to be
punished. And you always say that like SNL
should be put out of the job because a lot of the
things that Republicans do are just beyond parody
at this point. Yes. So like what would make you
believe like if it ever came out in a book or
something after Trump's death or something, that
he was just secretly a Democrat all this time,
just living that caricature that they've
set out for Republicans this entire time,
but actually just was elected to the presidency.
Speaker 1: I don't think so. So here's my thought.
I don't think that. So here's the thing.
The idea of Trump as a secret Democrat.
Doesn't really make sense in the sense that he
genuinely did so much damage like that would
make more sense if Trump, quote, pretended
to be a Republican and then became president
and did a whole bunch of stuff that Democrats
would do. But Trump became president and then
did all sorts of horrible things that Democrats
would never do. So what I think the scam is,
is that Trump was relatively apolitical. He
based on where he grew up, Queens, in Manhattan.
He probably was a sort of casual center
left guy. His entire life. And then
he just doesn't have the morals to say, I'm not
going to pretend to be something I'm not. But he
said, I'm not going to win the Democratic primary.
I can only win the Republican primary. He got some
traction with criticizing Barack Obama. And so
he was never a committed a real Republican in
a sense. It's just he's developed this character
for his political presence out of expediency. But
like the secret Democrat idea in the way you're
proposing just doesn't really make sense to me.
Speaker 4: Okay. Yeah, it was also part
of that, like what you mentioned that like
maybe he was taking one for the team or something
like that in a sense, but. Okay, that makes sense.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend, thank
you very much for the call. The audio. I
bumped the audio up as much as I could,
and hopefully we were able to hear him